so
let's have nick and your partner
doing miroti dory now you don't have to
hold strong
but but because they do hold strong
they're gonna do it their way
he could just have open hands and it
would be this should be the same
technique so so what we're going to ask
you
we're going to ask matthew say out loud
when you feel that nick is dominating or
taking over your comfort see he's really
comfortable now oh god him
i've got a grip on him now so he's
confident
leave him confident means that you've
had timid in because
his mind thinks that he's winning
he's got to leave matthew with that
thought all the way through now
matthew's going to say when he thinks
that that's changed do you understand me
okay
it's changed changed
so now
bulk is hitting bulk
so
nick's got to find a way of not letting
matthew be disturbed because what
matthew's going to do is it's built in
us he's going to try and hang on because
he can't see behind him he might not
like hitting the floor especially with
no mats and this is another reason why i
didn't bring the mats
and and you know as big as you are as
old as you are you don't want to you
don't want to fall backwards do you or
if you actually do actually don't care
okay you're a bit thick all right
i don't mind
it so many times i don't think anymore
okay so so you're gonna say again so
nick's gotta try to stop the block so
you're gonna be doing this in a minute
you don't have to grip strong all i'm
saying is sensitivity would tell you
oh you blocked him there
wouldn't you say
i felt it so you should have said yeah
okay
this is where i'm a bit hard
i
right good
okay yeah so it's no good is it
you know you can go in there it's
finished
okay so try again
so so nick might be here
until 4 30 and we go what a great day we
had we just walked there right there oh
so he's
he's
this person he's not being attempted
anymore because he's
realized that
the guy's trying to fight him so the
technique's not working
so let's go through that okay
so so what you're doing is you're doing
everything correct believe it or not
he's doing everything correct but what's
happening is he's dropping his shoulder
he's going soft but now he's he's
deciding to go in
but he didn't tell me to go in
so if i'm the puppet of the attacker and
using his strength
i've got to think
are you still happy that you're
comfortable i'm so happy and i didn't
block you no
so i'm going to just creep this leg
behind him and it's difficult
and this one's been that one's straight
and i'm going to just slowly creep up
his body
with this nice lightness you see he's
still feeling comfortable
you see
now you might not this might not be a
successful one the kaitenagi might have
been a bit more successful but i just
want you know here's your partner he's
going to give you feedback all he's got
to do is say block that's going to bug
your ego because you don't like being
told what to do
but you're going to have to live with
that bit
because it's going to be telling you
that your aikido is not perfect just yet
it's being blocked
and it's because
he wasn't um trying to mirror imagine
he's trying to go in you see
he's trying to go in now see where this
arm is here
it doesn't look any shape of this person
here
so if you was thinking about this
person's shape where should mark have
gone
towards the window
all right so what he's done is he's like
the kaitenagi when you go
like that one's directions there the
other direction is wrong so what you do
is you bring these two together like
that and as they get closer you
redirect their power what aikido says
you go like that
and you redirect it so what
he's done was he actually didn't
redirect his power he went into his
power so this shoulder used to go back
there
where matthew is
no not quite
when i see this arm
matching up with this arm
then i know the angle is right
right
don't worry about bending it yet right
can you now see
that this line
you can't see come close
this arm and this arm
is running
in line
before it wasn't
so now
he can hold that tension that uh he's
given him you must hold that not in the
center of me outside of me and he then
moves his body around that
hold
it's all wrong
don't worry about it right step behind
him
right but he's still strong
so what he does now is he keeps that
firm but he doesn't move this he forgets
he's got that now but he just says okay
i'm going to leave you powerful but i'm
not going to use you anymore and he now
tries to straighten his front leg so
he's working on his legs and his hips
the arms don't need to work
and that's where all of you are going
wrong you're still using your arms too
much
so you're looking
for
ah you're looking
for that
and how many techniques do you want me
to show you you know
can't take my sending me i can't give
him a center here
see
once you actually realize that i'm the
puppet
of the person
i must i must uh do what i can do
with their instruction even though they
don't know they're instructing me
the moment i try to go
they're saying well he's different
he's blocking he'll bolt me
so let's do
since he used to do this as well people
only think iwama style is this he's just
gonna hold hands open
like that
you still feel
the pressure so
okay okay is like this now
he must not feel
an increase
there at all
so i'd like you to open arms now
to realize
that the moment you feel it getting
stronger
you're gonna break that plastic
fork
as soon as you have to dig in
you're using strength and you can't then
take a a young girl or a young
person you can do like you know you can
do host senses like but this is how i do
it
you know
so so we've got to but not tell them
lies but first we must find our truths
and this is what this is what this is
about
right so please just keep trying
no i'm gonna block you'll know before
you do it
you don't have to be a sex down
to know
that
on the block
i know it he knows it
i'm going to block
you'll know it before
so why go into it thinking oh well
perhaps next time oh well perhaps if i
keep doing it it'll get better it won't
it will just keep blocking
as far as i'm concerned i do the same
it's just that you don't see what i'm
doing
so we've got to go from
a
b c to abercro you know
okay